ah
[Música]
las cuarentenas y el distanciamiento
social han hecho que el uso del internet
en eeuu haya aumentado cerca de un 25
por ciento desde que empezó la pandemia
el incremento en el uso también ha
aumentado los crímenes digitales y los
riesgos asociados al robo de información
privada además en el pleno año electoral
los mensajes de odio las teorías de
conspiración y las noticias falsas
encontraron el terreno arado para su
propagación sobre todo con líderes como
donald trump que hicieron eco de estos
mensajes en redes sociales que entre
otras cosas cuestionaban el virus y sus
efectos razones que llevaron a facebook
ya twitter a suspender indefinidamente
las plataformas sociales del ex
presidente días antes de que saliera de
la casa blanca' y tras los ataques al
capitolio muchas organizaciones privadas
en eeuu celebrarán este día haciendo
webinars y podcasts sobre la seguridad
en línea y cómo mejorar la forma de
encriptar las comunicaciones privadas
[Música]
todo comenzó cuando twitter y facebook
suspendieron las cuentas de redes
sociales de donald trump entonces el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
dijo que no estaba de acuerdo con ese
tipo de censura y anunció que impulsaría
la creación de una red social pública
que no dependa de los intereses
económicos de las transnacionales la
idea generó mucha polémica y esta
controversia se ha acrecentado aún más
cuando el senador ricardo monreal líder
de la bancada mayoritaria de morena en
la cámara alta anunció una iniciativa
para regular las redes sociales twitter
facebook instagram
iniciativa que ya subió a su página
oficial esto ha generado muchas
reacciones entre ellas la de la
organización artículo 19 que alerta de
una posible regresión democrática sin
embargo montreal argumenta que lejos de
provocar la censura lo que busca es
garantizar la libertad de expresión
evitar que se difunda el odio e impedir
que las empresas violen los derechos
humanos de los ciudadanos la discusión
está abierta en el congreso pero también
está muy presente en la sociedad
mexicana
[Música]
en 2020 aumento en un 57 por ciento la
violencia en línea contra los menores de
edad en francia para una internet más
segura se fijaron tres objetivos primero
que los niños aprendan a manejar mejor
el tiempo que pasan en las redes
sociales mayor a prevención de la
ciberacoso mejor protección de sus datos
personales y también que aprendan a
detectar las informaciones falsas que
puedan encontrar en línea para esto hay
un portal internet en donde pueden
encontrar todo tipo de herramientas que
también están destinadas a los padres de
familia y además un número de teléfono
en caso de necesitar asistencia francia
está en una lucha constante contra los
contenidos ilícitos en internet en
especial la pornografía ya que 1 de cada
3 niños a la edad de 12 años ya ha
tenido acceso a este tipo de contenidos
ahora se espera que dé un paso adelante
en la materia de regulación de los
contenidos en internet esta vez a nivel
europeo con una especie de constitución
digital que fue presentada ante la
comisión europea a finales del año
pasado
[Música]